ils seront consacrés à michèle bernier
pour une double actualité
alors d'abord dolores claiborne théâtre
donc une pièce est avide jose peu claire
farah d'habitation d'après le roman de
stephen king et une autre cinéma
survivre avec les loups un film de véra
belmont assez étonnant sur le périple de
cette petite fille pendant la guerre qui
va réussir a échappé un dessin
enfin moi je presque quand on voit cette
quand on raconte cette histoire en grand
pas et pourtant c'est une histoire vraie
le fait que l'amour de caila pour ses
parents est plus fort que tout quoi non
plus fort que de mourir de faim et et
elles se retrouvent à un moment presque
morte et il ya une famille de loups qui
la récupère et qui là qu'il fallait lui
donner à manger lui redonner la vie
alors dolores claiborne maintenant je
crois que c'était fait dire dans c'est
vous qui est à l'origine de ce projet
c'est vous qui avez lu le livre qui a eu
envie qu'on l'adapté c'est à dire que en
fait moi je cherchais un spectacle une
pièce pour essayer d'être dans un
registre
- habituel
c'est faire rigoler et et je me suis dit
tiens je me font très bien quelque chose
d'un peu différent
alors voyons un peu de quoi il s'agit
alors de l'aurès et une servante verra
sa maîtresse aux riches âgées meurent et
elle est accusée va y avoir donc des
aveux qu'ils vont montrer que la victime
n'est peut-être pas ce qu'elles croient
pas voilà c'est simple non pas cette
idée alors qu'est ce qui vous a séduit
dans cette baie à la fois parce que
c'est un personnage qui reste populaire
un personnage vrai et dolorès pour moi
c'est mille et une femme qu'on a pu
croiser qui ont eu des vies lesquels
n'ont pas eu le choix et qui se sont
retrouvés avec des hommes plutôt violent
et qui se sont défendus que peut-être
mettant plus maligne que les autres
alors quand vous utilisez cette volonté
de changer de registre et de quel type
c'est parce qu'il y en avait marre de la
michel vergnier rigueur ne pas me mords
moi j'y retourne voilà j'avais plaisir
altor j'adore j'adore non mais je suis
toujours à lui signer comme on sait
jamais étonné de la carrière d'un michel
serrault ou d'un jacques villeret qui se
sont baladés tranquillement dans tous
les gens qu'on passe de la cage aux
folles où j'arriverai de la soupe aux
choux à des choses plus dramatique
donc je me suis dit mais moi pourquoi
pourquoi est ce que seraient cantonnés
dans un genre
une amérique mérite
je suis pas très violent je trouve alors
qu'elle sort car si j'avais eu envie de
frapper ça peut-être la culture moi qui
suis en tournée dans toute la france par
exemple je déteste cette idée qu'on a
classifié les gens les gens et les gens
c'est à dire qu'il ya des tas de
théâtres municipaux par exemple qui sont
en queue qui a entretenu par l'état et
qui font des choix culturels pour leurs
abonnés qui sont totalement je dirais
fasciste quoi c'est à dire on décide
qu'un tel a le droit de vie et l'autre
donc loti peut aller comme ça jouer du
théâtre subventionné était à
subventionner ces espèces de guerre
qu'on installe tout le temps et qui fait
que la culture devient de plus en plus
dure et la culture jolie avec un grand j
d'après eux devient de plus en plus en
fait 2 s'éloigne de plus en plus des
gens est et ce qui aurait pour être une
vraie variété parce qu'on a une chance
inouïe donc d'être très variés dans
notre culture en france
on a aussi bien la gaudriole l'humour la
dureté les les mots enfin on est quand
même très fort là dessus et on on est
tout le temps sectarisation êtes orthez
là par exemple pour retourner comme
celle là vous vous heurtez à des
municipalités qui dit oui ça me ça
m'emmerde de pouvoir sur un spectacle
comme dolores ou même sera spectacles
joués avant que sa peine lui dit vrai
saut j'ai joué avec justement avec avec
pascal légitimus quand même balasko cas
karim une des pointures du 03 juin et du
populaire mais dans le bon sens par le
bon sens
cher pourquoi est-ce que tout d'un coup
on n'a pas le droit de jouer dans une
ville comme metz par exemple danse dans
le beau théâtre non un très beau qu'on
aille jouer dans un endroit qui n'est
pas obligatoirement fait pour ça qu'ils
aient fait plus pour des concerts de
choses comme ça
pour pouvoir aller vers les gens donc on
peut s'exprimer ça veut dire que nasa
pays de liberté le jour on commence à
dire aux gens d'une certaine manière qui
n'est pas qui est une manière sournoise
qui ait jamais ostentatoire on dit pas à
quelqu'un toi tu es comme ça donc t'as
pas le droit de parler on fait genre bah
on coupe un peu les moyens on dit que
ben non c'est pas possible comme ci ou
comme ça on met des les rois des matches
et que les choses c'est l'époux de la
peau de chagrin
et tout d'un coup on n'a rien vu
rien fait et hop il ya plus personne il
ya une culture unique pour des gens
unique donc ça ça me semble un truc qui
est prosaïque nature non et c'est un
moment que j'attendais les mii sur tout
le monde se tait
il ya un respect quand même à l'autorité
alors ce coup de sifflet ce ping-pong
c'est l'occasion en règle générale pour
nous de sortir des choses qui sont
agréables mogren on va pas dire ça alors
on a des petites revues de presse comme
celle ci par exemple
alors qu'est ce qu'on voit michèle
bernier mai et un petit problème je lis
les gros titres
désolant michèle bernier est encore
formidable bon ça me va pas moi mais qui
osera flinguer michèle bernier
michèle bernier pas de mauvaises
critiques ça devient louche alors bon on
a cherché alors on a trouvé dans
première un petit quelque chose qu'il
faut creuser
il vous faut creuser alors donc cédant
première et c'est survivre avec les
loups l'oncle films devaient ramer lyon
dont on parlait comment une fillette
juive traverse à pied l'europe en guerre
pour tenter de retrouver ses parents
déportés quelque part alès véra belmont
peine à trouver le ton juste trop
esthétisant trop fasciné par l'amitié se
crée entre la gamine et les animaux qui
l'accueille trop insistant dans sa
volonté d'asséner sa morale paradoxale
si l'homme est un loup pour l'homme
le loup lui cet être humain son film
échoue a provoqué une émotion véritable
quand on entend ça qu'on se dit bah on
se dit que c'est que c'est bas il a le
droit de penser ce qu'ils pensent mais
ces premières messieurs 1re premier
banal chez moi je pense que c'est c'est
dommage
d'être aussi négatif sur le film que
vera en plus a mis beaucoup de temps à
pouvoir monter que c'est un travail de
titan que
je trouve dommage d'égratigner une si
jolie histoire et que je pense aussi qu
aujourd'hui par les temps qui courent
c'est toujours bien de rappeler que
c'est pas simple et que si par exemple
quand c'est la vie est belle on encense
et puis parce que ça vient de l'étranger
et puis quand c'est chez nous c'est
jamais bien alors on n'a pas trouvé nous
lissons d'aller chercher ce qu'il n'a
pas eu dans l'histoire et dans la
carrière de michel bernier une critique
qui vous a touché un peu qui vous a un
petit peu orthez je dirais heurter c'est
ce qui quelquefois est assez
désobligeant dans une certaine presse
c'est d'être réducteur je me rappelle
c'était dans libé il y avait il y avait
un téléfilm que j'avais fait qu'ils
passaient et là le truc que vous savez
ils annoncent les programmes et en
dessous ses marques et michèle bernier
et du théâtre de bouvard
ça faisait 20 ans que j'y étais allé que
j'étais plus et depuis j'avais fait je
pars combien de pièces plus ses démons
midi qui a été un gros succès et caetera
et lui semble et tout d'un coup je me
dis mais pourquoi autant pourquoi
chercher ça voilà pourquoi chercher à
réduire quelqu'un c'est que quelque part
il ya une animosité
et comme en plus il sait pas quoi dire
donc il fait ça voilà
[Musique]
ce miroir qui figure l'admiration pour
quelqu'un qui vous choisit d'admirer si
je puis dire ce soir à part vous coupez
garder que je faisais cela je le montre
tout de suite ça à l'aesa minnelli
robert de niro new york new york
alors on comprend pourquoi mais alors
quand même pourquoi pourquoi je sais pas
c'est une émotion absolue la lisa
minelli l'apprend fois que j'ai vu je
vois la salle bien rentrés dans le coeur
et sert déjà me sens voulez-vous que
c'était cabaret pendant qu'on fait avant
et
non je crois que ces cabarets l'a
vraiment à la vraiment première fois et
puis après à new york
et puis depuis j'ai un gros tatouage
quoi jeu on fonde moi quoi je suis allé
la voir à l'olympia la première fois
qu'elle est venue en france santé j'ai
pleuré volant 2h30 d'émotion voilà c'est
quand on en est à ce point et gossau
c'est quelque chose d'autre que
simplement le talent artistique qu'est
ce qui vous touche t elle ben je crois
que c'est sa fragilité
en fait c'est sa simplicité et de le
travail qu'elle a calé à tous quelle
sauce elle donne et là vous avez pu la
rencontrer et la ccir mon rêve
j'ai encore un rêve à vivre ceux qui
vous écoute je pense que tout le monde
est au taquet au tout le monde c'est bon
silla elsa rixe par la bac on doit tout
cas on va passer de fausses idées néron
venir il est bien évidemment oui si la
construction parce que bon leur semble
bah pas mal pas mal je crois qu'il a il
a annoncé qu'il arrêtait brunes feuilles
des postures clair parce que bon on a
une histoire ensemble c'est pour ça ah
d'accord moi c'était un coming out alors
ça te rend chez le dernier cette caméra
que je vous remets oui voilà plus
glisser votre marque ou es ce que vous
avez décidé de nous emmener dans un
moment de votre d'intimité de michèle
bernier j'allais dire des anecdotes avec
votre père ou avec cette petite bande
qu'est ce qui vous reste deux comme ça
est ce qu'il ya des moments de franche
rigolade ou vous reste un milliard et
demi
évidemment d'abord parce que moi je suis
né des cheminées presqu'avec donc
je suis imprégné je dirais mais c'est
vrai que j'ai des souvenirs à l'époque
dans les années 60 dont covéa qui rit il
papa et remettez le prix salue le prix
bête et méchant qu'on avait remis à
francis blanche à jean christophe averty
c'était pour les réserver aux réponses
la voilà et donc il avait trouvé un
endroit qui était à côté de notre dame
qui s'appelait la question où c'était un
espèce de bistrot boîte quoi et on
mangeait du pot-au-feu et après on
remettait le prix et après c'était
jusqu'à pas d'heure quoi et moi je me
rappelle maud mes parents m'emmenaient
samedi soir petite fille et j'avais 6 ou
7 ans et je m'endormais sont les
banquettes voilà avec eux et j'entendais
tout le monde là bas ça gueulait sachant
thèse a rigolé etc et puis matin à 5h30
6 heures il me récupérer et puis on
passait dans les halles qui était encore
à paris et il acheter à manger pour le
midi on rentrait tout le monde dedans
mais jusqu'à 2 et voilà
et ce prime était méchant c'est dommage
que le revenu bah je sais pas s'il ya
encore des gens qui le mériteraient si
oui c'est vrai que parce que c'était
quand même une vraie distinction
oui il fallait c'était bête avec talent
voilà c'était pas le prix commence de le
prix citron et gérard maintenant voilà
où c'est enfoncer des portes ouvertes
c'est tirer sur les ambulances on s'en
fout quoi je veux dire c'était pour
mettre à l'honneur des gens qui avaient
quitté des vraies bêtes et méchants
c'est à dire des cyniques des subversifs
des drôles de 20 à quelque chose qui
avait une vraie valeur aujourd'hui c'est
vrai on s'en fout
euros alors on s'en fout en tout cas
c'était un petit coucou sa part vous
imagine traversant les halles dans les
bras de ses puits ayant vécu bande de
fous et c'était génial dette avec une
bande de fous et temps en temps ce
départ était comme ça un petit pincement
il vous montre tout simplement tout
moment l'ambiance des soirées c'était
des délires de dagg personne ne ferais
ça
voilà ça c'était votre votre petite
vidéo ati moore on voit un peu tout si
ce qui vous a fait et ce qui vous manque
encore un petit peu tous les styles est
jolie mais heureusement mais c est qu il
ya eu une et les guignols et tout ça
enfin toute cette partie lac qui remonte
un peu le côté un peu action voyous quoi
voilà c'est ça qui manque au rapid
voyons bah écoutez voyous sont des
escrocs aujourd'hui n'est pas pareil on
se dit on ne pouvait pas imaginer qu'un
jour on regretterait nos voyous et
pourtant si on les regrette michèle
bernier pour sa pièce dolores claiborne
d'après un roman de stephen king david
jost buckley elle est actuellement en
tournée et ne manquez pas survivre avec
les loups le film véra belmont et
jugerait vous même de cette histoire
assez extraordinaire michèle bernier je
vous remercie
[Musique]